just say 1947 actually happened in New
Mexico there was a crash they would they
would step most definitely know that
information and not want to share with
anybody because of the the Roswell the
Roswell it was a they said it was like a
weather balloon right they came out
after the fact they came out one day and
said hey now keep in mind out in the
desert there this was the five-o ninth
bombing group they were the only group
that was authorized to carry nuclear
bombs they come out one day and said oh
we found a UFO and they come out two
days later and go holy [ __ ] we made a
mistake
it was a weather balloon I know we're
the only qualified nuclear group to
carry bombs and we didn't know the
difference between a spacecraft oh well
their balloon so that right off the
get-go making Liars made everybody think
wait a minute and then again now the
story start to come out all these years
later you have the children of the
officers that were there and one of the
guys he's a dentist today his father
brought him home pieces of it and he
said yeah my dad actually came and got
me out of bed and said come out here
look at this this is from another world
because i sat there is a 12 year old
little boy holding these irods he's I
beams in my hand looking all these
different signatures and different
designs that were on the metal and he
said that I was I couldn't believe it
and he goes then my dad came back the
next day and said hey forget all about
this forget you ever saw these don't
tell anybody about this get this out of
the house now so you know then then the
the the individual again I'm kind of
drawing a blank with his name now that
actually came out with this report and
was seen in wright-patterson Air Force
NIA now down over the oh I guess I was
wrong it was just a weather balloon
before on his deathbed he came back and
said it wasn't it wasn't it they made me
say that at the time but I'm on my
deathbed now there's nothing he can do
to me yeah they were extraterrestrial
beings there were there were other
people that saw them they were small
this is what took place there was
actually more than one crash he even
went to say as far as what brought them
down was radar cuz they were working our
new radar systems at the time and he
goes we brought it down accidentally but
we didn't even know we were doing
so it's kind of some more cool
information here like wait a minute
really
I remember hearing that portion of the
story yeah that connects to what Bob
Lazar was saying in his when they said
that he talks about the aircraft that he
was the spacecraft that he was working
on he said it was really small in there
he's like it would be for someone who
was like four foot tall five foot tall
like small person and they were
genderless they were like bodies that if
I remember correctly it was almost like
they were just cadavers that were just
sent there they weren't actual like
living organisms they were kind of just
like drone and there's more people
saying that today these aren't real
these weren't real entities they're just
dirt bright groan they are something
like a robot they're sitting because you
don't have to feed them let's not big
issues in space there's no plate there's
no place to piss and [ __ ] on one of
those aircrafts that's because these
things are genderless they what do you
put the food to travel billions of
light-years you know exactly where you
put all the food we have the same
challenges today how do you maintain
your health how do you maintain bone
mass and muscle mass and a no wait how
do you procreate
there were NASA was talking about the
other night how do you procreate in
space you can't mmm because everything
you're trying to do to have a baby is
gonna be counteractive and every force
has an equal and opposite force oh
you're gonna be all over the place yeah
listen to him talk about go to Mars you
know he said the week one thing we've
looked at is we can take your your um
your poo and you can put in a bag and
put it on the sides of the spacecraft
because it'll actually blocked out the
harmful rays of radiation so I said
that's one thing you can do with a don't
know that's a good but where's the food
coming from right how you gonna live for
six eight nine months on the trip out
there yeah how do you maintain that
muscle mass how do you maintain bone
density right oh by the time they said
they get there your your body wouldn't
be able to support the muscle the bones
would be so soft right so you know are
we going today tomorrow back to the moon
whatever you know did we go to the moon
again opens up a whole other can of work
yeah definitely but you know you look
back now they've got a new program well
they had a new program in DC called a
tip and it was let me see or what did it
stand for Stanford Advanced aerospace
threat identification and the guy that
ran the program was a retired veteran
from the
Marine Corps and got involved with it
and his name was Louis Elizondo and he
ran this for I want to say from 2009 to
2014 he's also the one that was
responsible for releasing the UFO that
the Navy's had recorded so he's the one
that actually got the information to
release those videos through the
Pentagon and he worked on this a tip for
all those years trying to approve or
disprove the fact that these vehicles
these UFOs these extraterrestrial beings
were actually coming to the planet right
and so he's you guys you could find him
now online as well as a host of
information with regards to black market
or black projects across the board yeah
advanced aerospace threat identification
program a tip AAT IP secret invested
secret investigatory effort funded by
the United States government to study
unidentified flying objects or
unexplained aerial phenomena UAP the
program was first made public on
December 16 2017 the program began in
2007 with funding of 22 million over
five years until the available
appropriations were ended in 2012 and it
hardly anybody knew how about a tip knew
who they were what what they're bad ever
heard of that yeah but again very cool
it's crazy how much money they this
small amount of money that they dedicate
to Space Research and the study to study
the science that goes into outer space I
think it's like something around like
five years ago it was around two to
three million dollars a year was what
the government was allocating to outer
space research or this kind of stuff a
tip stuff when the yearly cost to run a
McDonald's is something like 22 million
dollars like I say it's it's crazy this
is what kind of again I when I stations
with some of the moon you know hey we
went to the moon we didn't go to the
moon like listen why are we going back
you know it's pretty big deal if we had
been to the moon already why aren't we
back there now Oh Russians but I'll
listen dude the space force has taken
off there's more talk now
than ever than I've been alive on what's
really going on in deep space right I
would think we'd already have a base on
the moon if we had the capabilities to
go there or or shouldn't we have or do
we I mean I don't know if we do or not
or shouldn't we be spending money on
developing ways to mitigate the threat
of a an eight-mile-wide asteroid from
hitting the earth they're looking at
that we can see them when they're coming
we know when they're coming absolutely
if we no one's gonna there should be
which would be developing or spending
more money on that kind of research in
listen they are there you know some of
the challenges now as well how do you
how do you make this thing go away like
Armageddon right do you do you yeah do
you land on it and drill some holes and
put some Rockets on it try to push it
yeah do you use a microwave energy and
create enough of a push that you could
deflect it some other guys talk about
hey we will shoot missiles at it well
then if you break it up into pieces
they're still all coming from us in
pieces yeah I mean so you've taken a
item that's you know ten tons and now
it's like a buckshot of ten tons coming
into the u.s. yeah hit the world soap
right taking the consideration some of
the things we can and can't do you know
did we go to the moon if you go and look
at some of the different 18 moon people
they call them flat earthers oh but
don't believe that we went to the moon
it's compelling when you look at the
land the lunar rover and you look how
close to the the rocket nozzle sister
the ground go why is there a blast
crater into that thing I would think
right you know and then the the people
who defend it come out suppose it's an
adjustable descent mode or you can go
from ten thousand pounds to three
thousand pounds but it's still three
thousand pounds so to move a lot of dirt
mm-hmm and there's no mark there and
it's like powder sand and you know you
the the guys who are the believers will
come back and immediately hammering in
the ground I'm asking a question I'm
like less interested Apollo 11 and one
of the lunar landers looks like the back
of the lunar lander has these aluminum
slats or putting they were kind of put
in with maybe four rivets it doesn't
look like this they go four thousand
miles an hour and land on the moon
there's definitely so many questions
about the moon landing that outweigh the
proof that we did land on the moon right
I mean you know that we have is what a
video well the argument is this so how
can
millions and millions of engineers and
people who were took part of the program
how could all these people be wrong
right
and I'm like well listen if you look at
there was a movie called Capricorn one
mm-hmm that dealt with this is back in
the early 80s that dealt with landing on
they were gonna go to Mars and before
they took off they realized they
couldn't go to Mars so decided to make a
fake landing in Mars there is talk of
he's another he actually made the movie
2001 Space Odyssey of the director the
director he actually was given four of
the 10 cameras Carl Zeiss made the
cameras for the astronauts to take into
space and these were very specific
cameras lenses that could shoot in zero
light could have a candlelight and he
was shooting that well for some reason
NASA gave Stanley Kubrick is his name
Stanley Kubrick yeah they gave Stanley
Kubrick four of those cameras or four of
those lenses what yeah why the ten that
you made you gave four to Stanley why
would you give four of those to Stanley
Kubrick that doesn't make any sense to
me
oh by the way NASA was with him the
whole time that he made his movies about
the moon landings they were so what is
it they were apparently there were some
NASA consultants or NASA engineers
somebody who worked at NASA was on set
during the production during the whole
production I see the whole show yeah the
whole event and of course every now the
believers will tell you while they were
there because they were giving Stanley
Kubrick advice when the people from
Kenya Stanley Kubrick will tell you they
were asking questions on hey how did you
make that that meteorite strike in the
dirt away is that movie come out before
the moon landing I don't I'm not I keep
it after it was like nineteen came out
after yeah I want to say like in their
early 70 71 72 well if it was after the
moon landing then why would they be
trying to why would NASA be trying to
look for information from Stanley
Kubrick if it was after its well they
were they the story goes that NASA was
impressed because they're they're guided
all the handled their special effects
what he did was he went out and got
called Portland cement and it's like a
real fine powder and he made the setting
with this Portland cement well he would
go up 40 feet drop a ball bearing down
and it would make this strike that look
just like an asteroid and strike the
surface of the Moon yeah
so he did that to give this whole moon
like effect and the NASA folks went wow
that really looks real hey I got an idea
maybe we can't go to the moon we can
sure make it look like we went to the
boat so but again so the question for me
was why would you even give the Moon
videos already out at this point the
moon landing was already out um yes okay
yes they are okay yes they are but now
these to give remember now and maybe a
listen maybe maybe this movie was made
back a 68 so just in the Apollo 11 went
69 yeah so you probably look it up but
there was they definitely went there
during the same period
68 Oh Stacey ate a few thousand ones
Space Odyssey was released in 68
okay so Apollo 11 I think when 69 69 I
think it was 1969 that they went there
yeah 69 69 so it just had some strange
there were some strange listen nobody
wants to think that the US government is
lying about going to the moon
no oh it's impossible you can't well I
mean why are we having this conversation
then if it's a why if it's impossible we
can't why was stealing the moon landing
was one year after Space Odyssey came
out yep so that makes sense why they
were there because they were trying to
fall they were trying to to mimic or
making her out how they did it so well
bingo so it's I mean listen in the gut
is true but yeah I'm like well listen
why would NASA out of these ten lenses
that were made give Stanley Kubrick four
of them does it make sense to me they
want to use the same [ __ ] lenses they
wanted to make the same so there's a
factly right so interesting you know
when you start looking and then when you
start you know I I started looking at
like the the astronaut uniform they're
the spacesuits they wore yeah
the suits weigh about 475 pounds okay
astronaut suits the ones that used on
the walk on the moon with holy [ __ ] okay
now that again now kind of a project
question because what damn that's a lot
of weight well that the the atmosphere
there is one-sixth of what it is
on the planet so believe it or not right
with the that's with the astronaut
antibody the suits actually like 180
pounds if you take a hundred eighty
pound man put them in there you're close
to five hundred pounds and when they
started looking at the bigger picture
because they said listen the man's on
the planet he only weighs 60 pounds when
he's on the moon's surface well if you
start looking at him real hard and you
look at the size of the entrance into
the lunar lander look can that guy
really get in the lunar lander and that
thing can he get out of the lunar lander
in that thing what's the what's the
uniform made up well it's got a lot of
Kevlar and mylar in it well I know
Kevlar is heavy yeah I'm doing so I have
had a sixty pound we did we did a
backpack through the Appalachian
Mountains and I carried a 60 pound back
through the mountains that's a heavy
pack so you listen to these astronauts
talk on there as they're going around
collecting rocks it's you know they're
say good having a great time out here
man I'm not tired at all I can't do this
all day long I don't hear anybody
breathing hard and there's some
references to heart rates going up but
listen when you're when you're working
hard you're gonna be sweating you're
gonna be you're gonna hear that noise
you just don't hear that so again it's
kind of an odd duck thing like really I
would think you guys be hoping a puff a
little bit more yeah up there how did
you keep the lunar lander you know it
was almost 400 what 375 degrees on this
when the Sun was out and so you got to
keep the air conditioning on the lunar
lander for a long time where's that fuel
coming from was from a battery look on
batteries and how how good to be have
batteries back in the 60s yeah you know
they weren't very good in the 80s I put
that small just isn't getting hold of
charge so you again you start kind of
looking at the ducts and you like well
you know if it looks like a duck and it
quacks like a duck is it really a duck
there's there's nothing else because I'm
gonna go with it it's the fact that it's
a duck but you know you again taking
into consideration you look at
everything that's going on and today
that thing looks so flimsy look like
it's made a tin foil
dude it's there's actually a video where
guy comes out and kind of makes fun of
the whole thing but I'm looking I'm like
he makes sense yeah and the believers
man will come out and just blister you
with regard I can't believe you're
unamerican and blah blah and believe it
not a lot of guys are even from person
is they considered an American to
question the moon landing the people I
talked to you said it was now the funny
part was that some of these most these
guys were
from the UK okay so why do you guys have
a dog in this fight what do you care if
yeah on to the moon or not well it's
ridiculous that you would think that you
didn't know you didn't answer my
question why did somebody in the UK care
about what we did on our space program
it's kind of bizarre to me I would think
you'd be you know one of the guys maybe
at NASA who's a who retired from there
and mm-hmm I want to tell you why it's
not fake yeah well it all goes back to
that thing you know people just want to
look for things that reinforce what
they're what they already believe or
what they're already what they're
already looking for I agree I think
that's exactly what happens but you know
we get when you take into consideration
these events from a tip or skinwalker
ranch or the US Navy that our inner
taking place they say listen if you talk
to somebody usually they've got kind of
a story that's kind of paranormal that
you know me incorporate something else
like I've never seen a ghost
well you know I don't know if I
necessarily believe it or not but I yeah
I haven't seen him I other friends of
mine who've seen him and said oh my god
you know scariest thing I ever saw in my
life
most terrified I've ever been and I
figure why haven't I seen one why what's
the difference is they're not taking the
right no you don't taking the right kind
of drugs that's the problem
[Laughter]